este lunes iniciaron y ya los discursos
de líderes mundiales en la Cumbre
climática de la ONU en Egipto la co-27
que busca Elevar los compromisos de las
Naciones contra el calentamiento global
entre más de 200 invitados esta jornada
corresponde a las intervenciones de los
jefes de los grandes productores de
petróleo Arabia Saudita y emiratos
árabes Unidos que quieren un papel
futuro para los combustibles fósiles
también están en la agenda los primeros
ministros recién posesionados de Reino
Unido e Italia y países empobrecidos
como níger que esperan financiación que
sustente la lucha climática Asimismo hoy
habla el presidente de Francia emanuela
de macron
vamos a conversar sobre la Cumbre que
inicia y para ello nos conectamos en El
Cairo con Verónica Arias ella es experta
medioambiental y director ejecutiva de
la coaliciones de ciudades capitales de
las Américas frente al cambio climático
cc35 Verónica el agradecimiento es para
usted la organización es meteorológica
mundial ha dicho que los ocho últimos
años han sido los más calientes
registrados en la historia dicho esto En
qué estado llega el mundo a esta con 27
bueno llega en un estado de emergencia
climática definitivamente un llamado
atención porque vemos un agotamiento de
la presión que se ha venido ejerciendo
desde el acuerdo de París y un poco y ya
faltas de credibilidad frente a aquellos
compromisos que se hicieron y un
llamamiento a que ya Comencemos a la
implementación Y de hecho esta cop 27 se
llama la top de la implementación creo
que todos los líderes que hasta el
momento han hablado han hecho un llamado
justamente a a que se haga la acción se
implemente se comience ya a hacer no
tanto bla bla No tanto pues negociación
sino que ya queremos acción Así que este
es el el momento que se está viviendo
acá
creemos Pues que con todos los
con todo lo que sea ha dado a conocer
más de 24 países solamente
han podido generar sus compromisos
nacionales determinados de los 191
países lo cual es preocupante porque
deberían haber sido muchos o más
ambiciosos y se esperaba que en esta Job
llegue y a los países con compromisos
muy mucho más más fuertes Especialmente
los grandes líderes como los como china
como Estados Unidos y el financiamiento
tampoco es que se ve así que hay una
polarización entre los países
desarrollados y los no desarrollados y
sin embargo la verdad es que estos
discursos de las cups siempre se
caracterizan por tener precisamente eso
muchísima retórica y pochis poca acción
sobre la mesa ahora vamos a hablar antes
de pasar a los países que son mayores
emisores Hablar a la de la guerra entre
Rusia y Ucrania de que ciertamente ha
cambiado el panorama para esta copa
muchas economías industrializadas se han
visto afectadas por la crisis energética
y por ello han tenido que acudir
nuevamente con más fuerza a recursos o
como las centrales nucleares o incluso
de Carbón es posible Usted cree que se
haya un equilibrio a mediano plazo para
beneficiar a la lucha climática en medio
de esta crisis que nos generó la Guerra
de Ucrania
no definitivamente no Y ese es uno de
los factores importantísimos que va a
golpear al mundo y a las conversaciones
y negociaciones globales Porque fíjate
que de todas maneras Nos estamos
avecinando especialmente en los países
del Norte A y en Europa aquellos
compromisos que se hicieron en su
momento ahora con un contexto
geopolítico muy complicado y un invierno
que se acerca no va a ser posible y a
muchos de ellos han dicho que primero va
a ser la gente y que pues no se mueran
del frío y que van a tener que volver de
cierta forma al uso de combustibles
fósiles de eso ha generado una reacción
es un retroceso
en las negociaciones y en las señales
que se está dando al mundo es por eso
que destacó es tan crucial y están
crucial también porque se va a generar
un balance global que se había dicho la
vez anterior y que vamos a comenzar ya a
trabajar en ella Valencia global para
ver en realidad si los compromisos que
se dijeron se están cumpliendo y
aquellos que no y por lo que vemos
pareciera que no Porque además es que no
no se avisora una solución a la vista
más con la Guerra de Ucrania ahora el ex
vicepresidente de Estados Unidos algo
ahora reconoció hoy en su discurso que
los líderes mundiales enfrentan por esto
que usted nos dice una crisis de
credibilidad cuando se trata de acción
climática a propósito de eso es que
muchos de los mayores países
contaminantes del mundo van a llegar a
la Cumbre hasta la próxima semana como
es el caso del presidente de Estados
Unidos joeyden qué mensaje arroja esto
precisamente hoy en la apertura de la
Cumbre con las reuniones de alto nivel
bueno exactamente además que se esperaba
que ya hay una confirmación de muchos de
ellos desde antes hasta el momento como
que las cosas están midiéndose a ver si
se vienen No se viene es decir están
tanteando Pues el terreno para ver si se
viene eso es un mensaje
lastimosamente no fuerte sino que lo que
necesito el mundo es oír los compromisos
y las acciones y pues simplemente no lo
estamos viendo en ningún momento y los
escenarios cada vez están más fuertes y
nos abrirámos al cumplimiento del 2.5
grados centígrados que es el peor
escenario que habíamos dicho con lo que
estamos viendo
versos los 1.5 que teníamos como
objetivo y sobre este mismo tema el
presidente chino tampoco tiene previsto
asistir a la Cumbre va a enviar un
delegado pero diríamos que es una poca
participación tratándose del mayor
emisor del mundo de de gases de efecto
invernadero India ni siquiera está en la
lista entonces son las Naciones que
ocupan primera y tercer puesto como
emisores de gases contaminantes Usted
cree que sin la asistencia de estos
países y con la asistencia tardía de
Estados Unidos realmente se puede pensar
en una lucha efectiva contra el
calentamiento global
bueno esas son unos señales muy débiles
para el multilateralismo y son señales
muy tristes del compromiso que están
generando las principales potencias
mundiales es por eso que lo que te
comentaba hay una desazón y un
agotamiento por parte de la gente porque
se esperaba mucho más y vemos que no no
no se están comprometiendo ni tampoco
con el financiamiento entonces hay que
seguir trabajando no perder las de
esperanzas y seguir presionando
efectivamente porque no vemos que hay
una conexión entre la humanidad y lo que
está pasando a nivel mundial y los
grandes decisores mundiales en este
sentido